I guess what surround sound means is
that right over here Jim
[Laughter]
figures
speakers
what honey oh Jesus this is terrible
we'll never finish this episode
um check this out
Folds
sorry oh my God I want you all to be
bavon's okay Avon is a girl's name
you need to shut the up
over the gums and through the lips look
out stomach
there we go
[Laughter]
do we have any muffins
yeah
take a longer pause before you answer
Pat I don't mean to be crass but get
prepared to get wet
because wow
there's no double meaning in that
wasn't you couldn't even get through it
it's the most horrible thing I'm so
sorry all right I'm the I'm The Candy
Man
Santa's come early
sure Santa Santa would like to Bear
Santa would like to buy you a pair of
panties little girl
Shannon
[Laughter]
wow naturally he hopes he can count on
your discretion you can do a better
place
very compelling argument
I'm sorry I am not a bad guy I am a good
guy
who runs over women with his car
I'm sorry that was so good I'm not a bad
guy I'm a good guy
who runs over women with his car
I am not a bad guy I am a good guy who
runs over women with his car why am I
having such a hard time getting my
message across
can you hear me what
what
I can hear you why are you calling me my
minutes don't roll over I have to use
them today
okay there's a press release that Ryan
would like I can hardly hear you
uh I know I used to be a temp here and
now I'm your boss and I understand how
that must be weird for you but you
I'm really sorry I broke that was too
good okay so we're all leaving for the
hospital at one o'clock free and free I
can take three
we're leaving for the hospital at one
Freedom tree oh
let's just go through that part okay
we're leaving for the hospital at one
like a freedom tree
okay Michael I might have someone for
you
here she's really sweet nice you guys
might actually get along
is she hot
that was such a bad day that was the
worst take ever Pam
what is wrong with me
so sorry you're standing in your closet
I walked into this man who's standing in
a closet
this is like ridiculously
if you don't deal with things right away
they only get worse it's called
appeasement
oh God
that is so disgusting
I ever need cottage cheese in a long
time
wow Michael
5K means five kilometers you put 5 000
miles on this flyer come in
hey oh my god oh yeah no Michael
you said come in
oh my God Michael is there anything you
need from Mike to go back to bed yeah
Joe just get some rest we'll see you
Monday unless you're still sick
um all right we'll have a great long
weekend I'll probably be just
laughs
you enjoyed that video
how old are you going to have kids and
I'm going to get married not necessarily
in that order and they're going to live
here what
yeah
I love you I love you Michael I love you
too what are you even talking about I
was just talking about I farted
are you kidding me I did oh my God this
is this is my place okay let's go back
to one hello Michael how are you good
how are you good to see oh sorry there
okay well why don't we just step in what
hey
going to be fine
tell him really that I am far too
valuable to you
[Laughter]
fire who
I I
what who is he saying I can't really
make it out
fire quiet you you know what those are
grounds
Michael
look at me
oh
nobody even signed my birthday posture
probably because it doesn't even look
like me it's from last year no
I'm driving
[Laughter]
you're making it work
no it's about my work situation and my
living situation and how they coalesce
into one another because I need a living
situation in order to do my job but
[Laughter]
I'll make you proud
I see the sales department are down
there they're in the engine room and
they are shuffling coal into the furnace
right I mean who saw the movie Titanic
they were very important in the movie
Titanic everyone in the engine room
drowned okay
oh
I Wanna Give You a nappy head because
you're Leslie
well that's not your character
laughs
it's too loud what oh it's too loud
right there anyway
I don't know why I did this
that's suddenly clearly a different
character
it's too loud
too loud we're almost there
even though this is a cul-de-sac
I missed my left
I want my baby back
baby back ribs
I want my baby back baby back baby back
I warm up
Chili's baby back ribs
chilies
no wait out the second one okay
[Laughter]
oh it says busiest no you screwed that
up didn't you
I guess we have to go back don't we
we're wasting a lot of tape give me that
all right